if this train derailment happened in
downtown Atlanta in the densely
populated black neighborhoods
this would be the number one news story
it would be Flint Water Crisis 2.0 oh
well that's interesting we know how
sincere Charlie Kirk is in saying he
would be just as concerned obviously if
the train derailment disproportionately
affected black people because of the
years that Charlie Kirk has spent
talking about the Flint Water Crisis oh
wait he hasn't spent years talking about
the Flint Water Crisis and so this is
yet again we are the victims it is
racist or it's Reverse Racism which is a
delightful term that they like to talk
about but what they won't discuss is
whether the train derailment might be
the result of corporate greed and
deregulation